hi everybody at entertainment tonight
come on in and we'll show you around
the momager is responsible for billion
dollar empires i'm proud of all my kids
kendall baby come here boo boo and
looking at et's time with the family 20
years ago we see chris cultivating her
family's success from day one and we
both are these control freaks when it
comes to our kids while touring their
home in 2001 some familiar dynamics were
already in place designer nancy whaley
curtis and this room became do we don't
sit on that you know i'm gonna do she
likes half up half down we have one more
hairstyle to do
so we can get plenty
of the little girls
are you excited
oh
kylie
that is so gross let me see your purple
teeth look at this
why somebody gave you a popsicle
kylie's turn let's put kylie right here
all right mr demille she's cameron right
here right here
sit right here come on
okay your turn
okay she just needs a bow
you know this house it's all about the
bow
while their backyard featured a putting
green a basketball court and even pony
rides the real highlight was kendall and
kylie's stunning playhouse we're in
kendall and kylie's dollhouse welcome to
their little villa that we have here at
the jenner house huh girls huh this is
where we spend a lot of time
this is like a little oh there goes
kendall upstairs so you'll see her pop
out the top
some of the pieces of furniture as i we
purchased them when the kids were not
even born yet what i loved was these are
pieces that they can have for the rest
of their lives i can see them taking
some of these pieces of furniture with
them when they move out and get
apartments of their own any fan of the
famous family knows how sentimental
chris can be
and earlier today my mom actually
surprised stormy with the best christmas
gift of all time
fast forward to 2019 the queen of gifts
once again outdid herself you surprised
me
yeah
who the
yep she actually recreated her youngest
daughter's playhouse
i used to have a house like this when i
listed from his age
[Music]
oh my not the welcome friends this makes
me want to cry
kylie's vlog gave fans a cribs style
tour showcasing the adorable open floor
plan hi
it's stormy's house
[Music]
stormy this was on my furniture when i
was a baby
look at the ironing boards
and you can go up there
look over wave to the camera say goodbye
[Music]